we need to trust each other we can't
fire war amongst ourselves with so many
enemies now what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back to talking
Thrones
once again I am joined by gray area and
today we are gonna finish our
predictions for Jon Snow if you did not
see the first video go check that one
out then come back here but we're pretty
much gonna pick up right where we left
off I believe the last question I asked
gray area was about Jon Snow's parentage
and how everyone in the north
more specifically Winterfell will react
to this and news now that they're gonna
find out Jon Snow is actually a
Targaryen and the legitimate heir to the
Iron Throne so what I want to ask you
gray is how do you think everyone will
react to this especially Jon's family
what do you think they're gonna say to
him when they find out he's actually a
Targaryen because we all know how sons a
stark feels about Targaryen so Sansa has
this thing in her mind where ray guard
kidnapped Liana and raped her Sansa
tells Littlefinger that in the crypts
sons that could really come out of this
really disliking Jon like Catelyn just
because he was born and there's like all
these things in the books where Sansa is
compared to Catelyn
she's more like Catelyn like
Littlefinger when when they're talking
about being a traitor silence of being a
traitor and she's talking with Cersei
Littlefinger says like she's more the
mother than the father yeah that's right
yes so I could see Sansa like having
this kind of loathing feeling for Jon
like you're gonna be your the king and
my father raised you as a brother you're
you're dead raped my aunt like she could
have that look I don't want her
but I'm not sure like she's always a
wild card for me because you never know
what she's gonna do yeah and we've still
seen a lot of tension between those two
and even though in the show they never
showed a scene with John and songs it
together until they reunited and Sean's
has said she was always mean to John
when they were younger and we never
really understood that because in the
show they don't show those scenes but in
the books you do get more hints as to
how Sean's it feels about John because
when Arya thinks about John it's always
in a loving way he's my brother
but when Santa thinks about John it's
always her bastard brother yeah she
never considers John her true brother
like bran and Arya and even Rob did
she's more like Catelyn look I keep
saying that she's not gonna be loyal to
John how far do you think they will take
that do you think something bad can come
out of that based off of how she will
feel towards John or do you think that
quote from last season will be echoed
again in season 8 about the lone wolf
dying in the pack surviving do you think
she'll eventually realize that she needs
her family and she will realize that
John is her brother no matter who his
parents are and that they need each
other I might give her the benefit of
the doubt cuz I'm like 50/50 on Sansa
I'm just hoping based on how season
seven ended Sansa will be full team
Stark at this point and stop trying to
undermine John or think of ways that she
can keep Winterfell for herself if
something would happen to John well now
that you say that she might be happy
that he is the rightful heir to the
Seven Kingdoms cuz then she would be
next in line for Winterfell yeah that's
true because we know bran doesn't want
it and he said he'll never be Lord of
Winterfell and I could easily see John
letting Songza keep her position because
he don't give a [ __ ] and he never really
felt truly at home in Winterfell
although that is his home
yeah yes so that maybe she'll be happy
about that but then you also have to
think like well he has to win the throne
first so I like she's she's little a
major wildcard yeah it's gonna be
interesting to see what they do with
that okay let's move on to the next
thing
basically since we've pretty much set up
everything that's gonna happen when John
gets to Winterfell where do you think
John will make his first contact with
the night king do you think they will
battle for the first time and Winterfell
or do you think John will try to prevent
that from happening by meeting the night
king somewhere else before he can get
there okay so when I gave my prediction
is this is solely based on the show
because in the books I think it's gonna
be completely different yeah and in the
show with like the filming stuff the
filming news and everything that we have
I feel like there is gonna be a battle
a great big battle at Winterfell like
those big huge sets with the siege
towers and stuff I think that might be
Winterfell and if they're doing if
they're building it big like that it's
gonna be a battle there yeah they've
pretty much completely remodeled
Winterfell and fitted the entire castle
with siege weapons and other type of
defensive weapons and we know pretty
much the entire main cast is heading
there and that's the castle we know the
most that's the one that feels most like
home in the north and that's a location
that just on a filming aspect they
already have built and us familiar with
and like you said by the photos that
have came out thus far we're definitely
gonna see [ __ ] pop off and Winterfell
and I have a feeling that's gonna be one
of the night kings targets he might take
out a few smaller places on the way and
that'll be kind of how the show deals
was slowing him down a little bit so
John can get home and deal with all the
him being a Targaryen and Daenerys
showing up and all that other kind of
stuff before he eventually has to face
him in the field
yeah that's kind of what I think we have
all of these unsullied and all of these
Dothraki that are all gonna be coming to
Winterfell but they're all not gonna be
able to fit inside of Winterfell gates
and inside of their walls so they're
gonna have like tents outside of the
walls and things like that like Dothraki
tents and I think we did see some
Dothraki tents from filming those people
are gonna be the ones encountering White
Walkers first the Dothraki and the
unsullied so you might see the knight
king but his first contact might happen
further south because I think they're
gonna have to kind of run for it really
to me the night King attacking
Winterfell doesn't make sense because
Winterfell has all these magical
properties and it just doesn't make
sense
but for the show standpoint like people
are more familiar with Winterfell like
you said and if the night King has just
dragon and you can't really put the
other two dragons up against this dragon
especially when they're vulnerable
to just be taken out of the sky very
easily so the only person that could
basically fight the night king is
Daenerys on drogon because drogon will
be a little bit you know he's gonna have
a rider so he's more easily controlled
he can duck things like we've seen
drogon duck things but drogon was still
hit by the scorpion so they're
vulnerable so what should happen is the
dragons should be put into the crypts of
Winterfell because we know that from the
books that dragons can go into the
crypts they've been in the crypts before
there's a rumor that
vormax laid dragon eggs inside the
crypts and one of the Targaryen Kings I
can't remember one Targaryen king or
another put his dragon in the crypts of
Winterfell while he was negotiating with
Cragen's dark so that
a thing in the books but in the show can
the Dragons fit inside the crypts I
don't know but I feel like the Dragons
need to be kept away from the fight we
could almost see something like that
because when that dragon was put into
the crypts that was during the pact of
Ice and Fire and you could almost say
we're gonna see something similar to
that with Daenerys showing up there and
her having to ingratiate herself with
the Starks yep so it could be another
pact of Ice and Fire basically like hey
I know we have our differences I know a
lot of bad blood was shed between our
families in the past but we need to
stand together if we're gonna survive
this winter and while they're there
she could keep them down there but I
feel like one I feel like when the
battle happens they almost have to use
those dragons even if Viserion is a lot
more powerful and a lot more faster and
the White Walkers could possibly be
chucking javelins while the night King
is on his dragon but I feel like they're
gonna need to use them in order to take
him down we're gonna have to see some
sort of a dance of dragons between the
ice and Dragons yeah definitely but I
don't know if it's I don't know if it's
that first contact you know what I mean
I feel like there'll be more than one
battle like I feel like something's
gonna happen at Winterfell and then
something's gonna happen a big like
there's gonna be like an attack on
Winterfell and then further to the south
there'll be a big battle in the
Riverlands how do you think they will be
able to flee and everybody make it
safely to another position to fight
without the night king and his army
being right there on them the whole time
I don't think a lot of people will like
will escape I think a lot of people will
be Maidan so it depends on does he
attack with the dragon does the attack
with the whites if he attacks with the
whites
I feel like it'll be easier to escape
where Winterfell could stand people
could literally just go in the crypts
and wait for him to pass over the crypts
I believe are magical I think in the
books the reason that I don't really
want him to go to Winterfell and don't
think that it makes sense for him to go
to Winterfell because I think if he
tries to go to Winterfell those dead
kings in those crypts will come back to
life yeah there's a lot of hints at that
happening with all the clues in the
books about the stone kings with their
eyes of ice and jeonse and the kings
stumbling out of their tombs and all
that kind of stuff it seems like they
could if they chose to do so because the
bodies weren't burnt is one thing but
there is magic like you say so but if
the knight King could get down inside of
there it's hard to say what he could do
he could possibly raise those kings yeah
but I think because of the magic inside
those crypts that he can't raise those
like if those kings are raised they're
gonna be raised to upholds him they
won't be fighting for him so I feel like
he would kind of want to stay away from
Winterfell plus we know when to fell has
magical properties the crypts in the
first keep is built by the children of
the forest but it for it to be for TV
six episodes there's there has to be
some kind of escape now we do know there
are secret passages out of Winterfell
because maester Luwin told Theon back in
like season 2 that there is secret ways
to escape if he needed to escape from
Winterfell when Ramsay Bolton had his
men around the castle
yeah he did tell him that and and the
white knife is a river that's really
close to Winterfell and it leads to
white Harbor and at white Harbor is the
Wolf's den inside the Wolf's den is an
ancient weirwood and inside there a pact
was made not sure about exactly what
that pact was but there was a king I
think his name was Brandon Stark and he
on a cruel winter and they his nickname
was ice eyes he went down the white
knife it was frozen he went down the
white knife and kicked the Raiders
killed the Raiders in the Woolston and
also the Wolf's den was built by King
John Stark so I feel like they could
escape that way and that might and they
might like take a secret passage that
leads them to the white knife and they
wound up at the Wolf's den because bran
is gonna need like if they have to
escape Winterfell bran is gonna need
access to a weirwood I feel like though
in the crypts of Winterfell it's a lot
like that cave so the roots of the
weirwood may be like if he was to go in
the crypts of Winterfell he could
probably still access the roots of the
weirwood but he would need he's gonna
need to be near a weirwood in order to
be effective yeah and um man I'm trying
to remember this quote now that you just
said that it was at the end of one of
branch chapters when he was escaping
Winterfell
after a Theon took it over he says
something it's at the very end of his
chapter and he's thinking about how
Winterfell is burned in on fire and he's
like Winterfell is not broken like me
the roots of the weirwood run deep
underground and as long as they stay in
the Stone Kings stay Winterfell will
stand or something like that yeah
Winterfell was built by the children of
the forest right and Brandon the Builder
yes the only parts of Winterfell that
was built by the children are the crypts
everything else was added over time
absolutely the crypts and the first keep
which has been rebuilt but it don't
that's the important thing the important
thing is the Crips and the Crips almost
to me seemed like a like a bomb shelter
they can go into the Crips and wait for
winter to pass and just say forget
everyone yeah they could if they had
enough provisions down there they could
camp out down there for a while but I
want to ask you something will the magic
and Winterfell hold up now that we've
seen the night King tear down the
magical wall with a magical ice dragon
could he penetrate through that magic in
Winterfell now that he he's pretty much
at his maximum powers too at this point
similar to how brands powers are
increasing would you think that magic
would still hold up with him having that
ice dragon I think that magic will hold
up as long as there's a stark in
Winterfell and the reason that I say
this is the reason that the magic was
broken the magic was broken in the wall
and the reason the magic was broken is
because the Nights Watch did not stay
true the Nights Watch
when they stabbed Jon they broke the
magic in the wall they weakened it
because they didn't stay true they
stabbed their Lord Commander to death
Mormont - yes they didn't stay true yep
I think that day as long as the Nights
Watch stays troop was part of that magic
that was holding the wall up because
this magical wall shouldn't be able to
be destroyed by anything right it's
strong magic and then you have to look
at there the saying there it always
needs to be a stark in Winterfell no one
knows why the hell they say that but
maybe that's part of the magic yeah it
definitely has something to do with that
and it has something to do with
the night king being able to destroy the
place or take over the place or raise
the Crips or anything like that like all
of those sayings stark needs to remain
in Winterfell when there is coming shoot
there's another one but basically all
that old stark stuff has to do with the
castle itself in the others I believe
yeah I I think so too and if you look at
the wall at the Nightfort there's a
magical door there and it's like shaped
like a weirwood and its mouth opens up
and the Nights Watch kid passed through
but only a Night's Watch can pass
through like no nobody else so the their
magic resonates with like people you
know what I mean like that
so only the Nights Watch can pass
through this door so of course they
whatever magic is going on in Winterfell
has to do with a stark in Winterfell so
only a stark in Winterfell must be able
to access whatever magic this is yeah
and it's might even be tied into the
weirwood tree too because why the Nights
Watch can only pass through the wall is
because of the vowel or the oath that
they say in front of the weirwood tree
and what their fel has that weirwood
system there - yep yeah I like that a
lot and that's all of this basically is
why I think Winterfell will not fall I
agree I don't think it'll fall I don't
either
and us I want to ask something that we
were talking about earlier about dragons
dancer dragons do you think Jon will
ever ride ragle in season eight to fight
the night king yes I do think he will I
think he has to um I don't necessarily
know if it'll be regal or drogon I know
a dragon will only take one rider but I
want it to be drogon I want it to be the
biggest and the baddest dragon but I
also really do think it'll be regal and
I just hope that it isn't
Cornie as I've told you before yeah I
hope so too but with John riding ragel
assuming that's the dragon he rides if
he rides a dragon and Danny riding Jovan
do you think that would be enough to
stop the night king or do you think it's
gonna take something even more magical
than dragon power do you think brands
gonna have to control something or get
inside the night Kings mind do you think
John would need a sword like light
bringer to bring him down what
ultimately will John and everybody else
need to do to actually beat him dang
that's like a million dollar question
[Laughter]
what's your guess what how yeah what's
your prediction for that what do you
think so
all the legends that we know of
[Music]
[Music]